- So wait, we shared some
throwback Thursday photos
for Jimmy,
So we want to see one for you too.
Is that okay?
- It's horrible.
- [Kelly] Okay.
Here's how I know we could
be friends. This photo alone.
- [Karla] Really.
- [Kelly] Yeah
We would've been friends.
What is happening?
- So this is just a regular,
you know, Saturday at my house,
my dad was really into us,
you know, getting dirty
Instead of pool parties,
we had mud parties.
For my birthday, my dad would literally,
next door there was just like,
there was no, no house
and he would just make a hole
and then put plastic on it
so that the kids wouldn't
get, you know, hurt
and then put the mud back
in, put the, you know,
the, the water and then
it would be a mud party.
- [Kelly] I love that.
He was a spa, before spa's were cool.
- [Karla] I know.
- Yeah.
[Kelly]we had something
similar called a slip N slide,
I look, yeah.
It's for poor people. Like
you just put the mat down,
you put some water on with hose
and then you end up looking like that.
- Yeah.
So we would put the slip N
slide onto like you would slip
and then you would slide
onto the hole of the mud.
Here, we would get soon.
- You were advanced. Okay.
Yeah. That's cool.
I wasn't that cool.
But I did like a slip N slide.
[Kelly]Let's talk about
your new show though.
It's called home economics.
So who do you play?
- So I play Marina. She's
a mom, an exhausted mom.
Just like me.
- [Kelly] Wow.
- You know, I relate.
- Yeah. I, I basically get,
I got to become a mom on TV on
how to get away with murder.
Then it's just, it's just, you know,
my bra size and my underwear
has changed, you know,
it's like now,
- Lucky
- [Karla] and then all
these different sizes
that I've been, have been,
you know, projected on TV.
And I've been playing these
parts as, as a mom, new mom.
And it's been, it's been great.
Cause I sometimes get
like tips from Marina
as to how to hide from my
kids when I'm exhausted
or like, you know,
things like that, that they write.
And I'm like, oh, that's good.
That's good. I'm going to
say that to my husband,
next time he tells me,
you know, just little,
little things like that.
- [Kelly] My tip is locks on doors.
- [Karla] Oh, but you got
to get the right ones.
- [Kelly] the bathroom.
I'm like, just give me a minute.
- Yeah, but I got the
one that's like on top
and you have to, it's like a thing that,
you know, goes in like a bat.
- [Kelly] like medieval
- cause the ones that
are just the sticky ones,
my daughter was like puh and that was it.
And I was like, yeah,
you got to get the lock,
the real locks.
- Okay. Okay.
I just have normal ones.
They've been trying to
break them down yet.
They're not as strong as yours.
- Oh really, but, how they're older?
- [Kelly] Five and seven
- Mine is three
- Oh my gosh.
- [Karla] Yeah, you don't
understand, my daughter,
the other day I told
her to not do something
that she really wanted to do.
And I was like, no,
Jenna, like, this is like,
no, we're not doing that.
She looked at me, she was standing.
She looked at me
and she started peeing.
- Just looking at you, like
- And she was like this, yeah
- [Kelly] and you're going to pick it up.
- And she peed down,
And I have read the books.
So I was like,
don't, don't this isn't don't, you know,
don't give her what she wants.
She wants the,
- [Kelly] React
- Piss you off, so I was just like,
all right, Aisle three needs a cleanup.
And I just left.
And inside I was like,
I was, no, she did it.
I was like, what kind
of daughter do I have?
- [Kelly] It's the reacting
though? You're good.
- [Karla] It's the reacting,
So I just pretended like,
I, you know, it was fine,
but she peed on herself to get back at me.
- [Kelly] The last time my son did that,
I literally walked him
directly to our wash machine.
I said, okay, take them off.
And you put them in there.
And then you use this
soap, and then you know,
and I made him do his own
laundry and I was like,
he's five. And he was
like four at the time.
- [Karla] But then, my
daughter liked that.
And she was like, oh yay.
We get to have fun.
Like, cleaning it up.
so I was like, oh
- That backfired.
- Yes,
- I knew my, I knew he'd be like I'm out.
- So he's peed on himself too,
[Karla]to get you, back at you.
- Dude. He's, no, he
didn't do it to get back.
He just, he just lazy.
He just like, didn't want
to go to the bathroom.
And I'm just like, you can't
just like pee everywhere.
And we also have a ranch, like,
On ranches, you can just kind
of pee anywhere outside there.
It's like, no one's there.
So, you know, guys, it's easy for them.
So, so I'm like, this is not a ranch.
- Oh and my daughter also
wants to pee like a boy.
Cause all the, you know, she's
like, they just stand up.
- [Kelly] My daughter too.
So, she love, Yep.